bonjour à tous bienvenue sur les chaînes
parlementaires à 45 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité politique avec
mme moracchini bojan nintendo dans
l'actualité cette semaine le statu quo
entre françois fillon et jean françois
copé
pourtant il se voit se pare en tête à
tête depuis le début de la semaine les
non-alignés pro entendre leur voix ils
ne veulent surtout pas d'un petit accord
entre amis en attendant le groupe
rassemblement l'ump est officiellement
créé à l'assemblée le dossier mittal
sème la zizanie au sein du gouvernement
le premier ministre a reçu les
syndicalistes de l'usiné de florange et
des élus de la région
rien n'y fait inquiétudes scepticisme à
la sortie de matignon
l'accord passé entre mittal et le
premier ministre ne passe pas et puis
nous finirons cette émission par une
exposition les dessins et dessinateur de
presse sont à l'honneur 90 croquis qui
ont fait l'histoire ont été accrochée
sur les grilles du jardin du luxembourg
nous recevrons en fin d'émission celui
qui chaque jour croque la vie politique
dans le quotidien le parisien le sait
dessinateur ranson et en attendant avec
nous pour commenter à cette riche
semaine benoist apparu bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau est
député ump de la marne j'ai bien dit ump
et non pas à horrues vous faites partie
de ces 122 députés qui n'ont pas rejoint
le mouvement de françois fillon le
nouveau groupe de françois fillon ces
trois dernières semaines on vous a
souvent qualifié de casques bleus
courant un peu partout aux quatre
colonnes pour apaiser les esprits
vous vous retrouvez bien dans cette
appellation casques bleus non parce que
ceux qui ont ce vrai métier là sont me
semble si on me semble-t-il des
fonctions qui sont tout autres
on va dire un casque bleu politique
peut-être oui parce que j'avoue que dès
le dimanche soir de l'élection
il ya trois semaines maintenant déjà
voir
deux membres du même parti politique se
taper dessus sur les plateaux télé c'est
un truc qui m'a paru m'a paru pardon
totalement ahurissant donc j'ai souhaité
mais pas avec d'autres bien évidemment
essayer d'apaiser la situation et
essayer de regarder des deux côtés ce
qu'on pouvait faire pour essayer de
rapprocher les deux côtés en question
était l'un des seuls à pouvoir faire ça
finalement puisqu'on l'a vu dans ce
qu'on appelle les quatre colonnes c'est
à dire là où rencontre un peu les
politiques les journalistes voient donc
on a l'occasion de vous voir et on a vu
que vous étiez l'un des seuls à pouvoir
faire ce maillon entre les uns et les
autres à yaya pas de monde qu'il l'a
fait heureusement d'ailleurs
ce maillon là il doit exister on est
plusieurs à le faire tant mieux il n'y a
pas de personnalisation à avoir sur ce
sujet comme quoi casques bleus peut
parfois s'énerver la semaine dernière à
passer dans cette émission même votre
coup de gueule vous disiez notamment
qu'il faut sortir de cette ambiance de
testostérone vous avez eu des retours de
oui parce qu'il ya un moment faire
monter la paire si la pression donc
c'est un coup de gueule choisi délibéré
il ya un moment faut accentuer les
pressions
parce que quand vous avez c1 pour
l'instant pour l'instant ça n'a pas trop
marché
si on est encore là on discute et c'est
que ça n'a pas marché du tout continuez
sur d'autres registres avec d'autres
formes mais la pression va continuer
alors c'est parti rhône ouvre cette page
ump c'est la semaine numéro 3 ils sont
d'accord
en tout cas pour se parler se revoir la
semaine prochaine voilà le bilan d'une
semaine de tête à tête entre françois
fillon et jean françois copé c'est dire
si la situation reste bloquée les
parlementaires eux commencent à trouver
un petit peu le temps long germain
andrieu c'est la quatrième réunion de la
semaine pour jean françois copé
direction le bureau de françois fillon
est pas un seul commentaire
quarante minutes d'entretien des
nouvelles négociations le jour de la
saint nicolas
mais aucune avancée pour fixer le
calendrier définitif d'un nouveau
scrutin
mais depuis hier côté fillon on refuse
le statu quo les non alignés ont fait
une fois
position ils ont proposé qu'on fasse art
vote beaucoup plus ouvert avec de
nombreux candidats et concours les
candidatures et qu'on fasse ça au
printemps
moi je trouve que c'est une proposition
qui est très constructive et pour moi
c'est une proposition qui est acceptable
les éléments qui étaient là pour faire
en sorte que les choses s'améliorent ils
sont tous passés ils sont en place et il
s'est rien passé
maintenant l'interrogation c'est ça moi
j'espère qu'on va parler ici fonctionnel
ces discussions aboutiront à quelque
chose première étape probable un
référendum auprès des militants pour
modifier les statuts et organiser une
nouvelle élection plus transparentes
or voilà benoist apparu c'est ce que
vous redoutiez le statu quo c'est ce que
je redoute effectivement le statu quo
nous sommes dans une situation nous
avons pour l'instant deux groupes ump à
l'assemblée nationale où nous avons un
président l'ump dont les résultats ont
été validés par deux commissions mais
sur lequel il reste toujours des
interrogations
ou en tout cas sur pèse une forme de
d'illégitimité le mot est un peu fort
mais sur lesquels il ya les
interrogations cette situation-là des
deux côtés n'est pas acceptable et ce
statu quo qui semble se dessiner
nous sommes un certain nombre à leur
refuser parce que ce statu quo ça
signifie la fin de fait si ce n'est de
droit de l'ump
le retour à une division formalisé entre
les uns et les autres et donc échec
électoral incapacité à répondre à
l'attenté des français bref tout ce que
je refuse tout ce qu'on refuse à
plusieurs ils se voient ils se parlent
depuis le début ça c'est déjà une bonne
chose dont on a fait une bonne chose
pour bien sûr rien ne transpire de ses
rangs des gones ont très bien
qu'est ce qui se passe mais nous
éclairer je sais que ça fait trois
semaines que vous ne savez pas plus que
nous et heureusement d'ailleurs
ça fait trois semaines que l'information
les discussions les négociations se
passent sur vos plateaux on a vu le
résultat
et j'ai rarement vu une négociation par
communiqué de presse interposée produire
un bon résultat là il se voit c'est déjà
une excellente chose ça transparaît pas
tant pis pour vous tant pis pour vos
téléspectateurs
tant pis pour moi pas plus au courant
que vous mais au moins ils se parlent
c'est déjà une bonne chose c'est une
situation compliquée difficile avec des
enjeux importants 6 à nos débouchés dans
deux jours ou dans trois jours on va pas
en mourir
françois copé dit maintenant on va quand
même par faire des élections internes
avec des institutions internes qui sont
contestées
donc c'est quoi la solution va faire un
référendum sur les institutions c'est on
va prendre
je ne sais pas c'est le premier que j'ai
avancé c'est c'est beaucoup plus calme
ça c'est des gens ont commencé à lire
les statuts et le règlement intérieur
mais on s'apercevrait que tous les
points qui posent problème les élections
sont de l'ordre du règlement intérieur
pas des statuts le règlement intérieur
ici d'un conseil national pour le faire
changer c'est pas très compliqué à faire
il suffit de s'enfermer quelques jours
dans une pièce pour effectivement régler
tout ça en trois secondes et dans des
élections
le règlement intérieur pas les statuts
c'est pas la même chose c'est pas la
même procédure il y en a une qui est
plus compliqué que l'autre donc réviser
le règlement intérieur c'est pas très
compliqué si on souhaite le faire on
peut le faire faut pas très longtemps
pour ça pour pouvoir effectivement
permettre l'organisation en délai bref
d'une nouvelle élection ouverte à
plusieurs candidats paru vous ne voulez
pas de ce statut quo imaginons une chose
un peu de politique fiction très
rapidement et si ça arrangeait bien les
deux candidats de cette situation
braquo je n'ose y croire c'est de la
pure fiction où j'ai touché quelque
chose tu peux je n'ose y croire et donc
de mon point de vue c'est de la pure
fiction bien évidemment vous connaissez
la petite phrase qui a souvent les dans
les films
toute ressemblance avec des personnages
ayant existé serait purement fortuite
c'est quelque chose qui est bien réel en
tout cas c'est qu'on sera prêt en soi
fillon qui a mis sa menace à exécution
mardi a été officialisé la création de
son groupe à l'assemblée le rhume une
réunion de groupe mais pas encore de
point presse le tout sur fond de coups
de gueule et des non-alignés mais aussi
des socialistes journée chargée ce mardi
à l'assemblée résumé par elisa
bartholomé il est arrivé très
discrètement ce mardi matin à la
conférence des présidents françois
fillon a rejoint les autres présidents
de groupe sans dire un mot
seul claude bartolone ce risque a
commenté cet événement exceptionnel à
l'assemblée nationale la scission du
groupe ump
le règlement prévoit que lorsque 15
députés décident de créer un gros et le
crès donc je suis là pour organiser la
marche de cette maison et nos travaux en
fonction de cette réalité réunion à huit
clos d'une demi-heure ambiance houleuse
selon cette photo prise par un
participant à la sortie aucun
commentaire de l'ancien premier ministre
nie du président jacob leurs collègues
socialistes ne se prive pas de critiquer
le comportement de l'opposition on ne
ferait pas de groupes politiques pour
convenance
politicienne pour convenance partisanes
pour essayer de régler les problèmes et
donc il y à là véritablement une
manipulation de notre règlement sa cause
de nombreux problèmes d'ailleurs dans la
réorganisation à la mi-journée les
tensions sont encore fortes
chaque groupe organise sa réunion
hebdomadaire d'un côté l'ump de l'autre
le rmp
un troisième groupe fait même son
apparition conférence de presse des non
alignés qui font part de leur
mécontentement
nous refusons le statu quo nous ne
voulons pas que la situation se fiche
dans ce qu'elle apparaît aujourd'hui et
pour ça nous demandons jeu même
mouvement un nouveau vote rapide et la
dissolution du groupe qui entre ce fait
les questions gouvernement ne sonne même
pas la trêve tous deux dans l'hémicycle
françois fillon et jean françois copé ne
s'adresse pas un regard en coulisse
salle des quatre colonnes l'appel à
l'unité continue d'être réclamés
arrêtons-nous castanier les uns les
autres et concentrons notre énergie pour
combattre la politique du parti
socialiste une création de groupes ultra
médiatisé mais sans ostentation
l'un comme l'autre camp assume peu cette
division alors françois fillon est en
train de recruter des collaborateurs ce
qui semble prouver tout ça s'inscrit
dans la durée vous l'avez vécu comment
vous cette journée vous avez vu comme ça
votre groupe se scinde et mal comme tous
les députés etc super aujourd'hui rhume
ou ceux qui sont restés au groupe ump
on le vit tous mal parce qu'on
s'aperçoit tous de ridicule total de
cette situation qui perdure la création
d'un groupe solde entre guillemets
l'échec d'un processus de discussions
entre les uns et les autres
raison pour laquelle nous devons
continuer à nous battre pour que ça
cesse le plus rapidement possible et
qu'il y ait recrutement de
collaborateurs ou pas c'est logique pour
faire fonctionner son groupe enfin ça
veut tout dire
ça veut tout dire ça veut dire
qu'effectivement ça sedan une durée et
donc on continue une pression de ce côté
là je peux le comprendre je peux le
comprendre il n'en demeure pas moins que
ça peut s'arrêter aussi en trois minutes
et on peut arrêter un groupe aussi entre
minutes bien sûr qu'on peut la résoudre
à munich on peut créer en quelques
instants peu le décret ou supprimer tout
aussi vite le rôle des non alignés
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est
pourquoi parce que vous ne siégeait pas
finalement avec les non alignés ou aussi
on vous a pas vu dans cette conférence
de presse mais pas c'est peut-être que
je suis partie juste avant la conférence
de presse mais j'ai participé aux deux
réunions en question la ligne et même je
me considère effectivement comme un drap
ligne et oui bien sûr parce que je
considère qu effectivement cette
démarche est positive qui consiste à
dire nous refusons de satu quo c'est ce
que disait nathalie kosciusko morizet à
l'instant pas de statu quo hors de
question d'avoir deux groupes
oui au nouveau vote cette ligne à c'est
la même depuis maintenant une dizaine de
jours de ces parlementaires qui refusent
le constat d'échec temps qu'elle nous
sommes oui un nouveau vote avec des
nouveaux candidats
écoutez moi j'ai plutôt le sentiment
qu'il faudra à nouveau avec des nouveaux
candidats
mais l'essentiel c'est d'avoir un
nouveau vote si les deux se mettent
d'accord et nous dise demain matin on
revote avec les deux mêmes
je signe tout de suite si besoin il me
paraîtrait peut-être plus judicieux
d'ouvrir le processus complètement mes
racines ou 10 ans 3 mois enfin vote à
deux je signe nicolas sarkozy
l'impression qu'il a perdu un petit peu
de sa superbe de sa crédibilité voire un
petit peu de cette stature qui lui
permettait un petit peu d'avoir la main
sur toutes ces personnes allaient
demander aux militants s'il nicolas
sarkozy a perdu ça ça sur sa crédibilité
je ne parle pas des militants c'est
promis auprès des militants non auprès
les électeurs non plus auprès des deux
peut-être parce que l'un et l'autre
j'imagine comment ça ce diamant va voler
notre propre hôtel c'est possible c'est
pas le sujet s'ils veulent tourner la
page
ils tourneront la page c'est leur choix
politique et je n'ai pas à juger ou à
contester les choix politiques de
françois fillon jean françois copé c'est
leur choix
le mien c'est de considérer de continuer
à considérer que nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui reste le patron de fait même
s'il est entre guillemets en retrait au
regard de ses fonctions actuelles regard
de son choix politique reste le patron
pour moi dans ma tête à moi je parle pas
de vous je parle pas des militants dans
ma tête à moi effectivement le père
spirituel
si vous voulez de l'ump ça reste nicolas
sarkozy alors se faire respecter comme à
main j'avais que je comprends dans cette
campagne électorale que les deux
candidats jurés leur fidélité
je me souviens d'un nous disant dès
qu'il revient je laisse les clés les
choses évoluent en quelques jours alors
vos collègues du parti socialiste vous
regardez hommes c'est vrai on va le dire
un léger sourire écouter les propos du
président de l'assemblée nationale
claude bartolone
ce n'est pas simplement un affrontement
personnel entre monsieur copé et
monsieur fillon voit bien qu'il y a des
des courants maintenant qu'ils portent
des analyses stratégiques ou idéologique
différentes au sein de la droite
française et je suis sûr qu'à un moment
donné ce débat apparaîtra au grand jour
derrière ces deux groupes il y a
deux visions idéologiques de vision
stratégique de conceptions différentes
de ce que doit être la réponse à
apporter aux problèmes de
la société française et ça finira bien
par apparaître
il a raison claude bartelone ya deux
idéologies différentes
je ne crois pas d'ailleurs on voit une
belle contradiction entre ce que dit
claude bartolone est ce que disait le
reportage avants bruno le roux inverse
complet à la politique revient
je ne le crois pas un gros pas oui il
serait temps qu'elle revienne rapidement
quand même maintenant je ne le crois pas
parce que j'ai pas eu le sentiment quand
vous regardez les projet politique porté
par françois fillon et par jean françois
copé qu'il y est à l'intérieur beaucoup
de différence alors on a eu des
tonalités très différente dans la
campagne électorale
mais c'était des tonalités de campagne
électorale savez si vous regardez la
campagne électorale de françois hollande
c'est pas vraiment une campagne
électorale social-démocrate et pour ton
peuvent a le sentiment jury qui gouverne
en seule démocratie vous connaissez
l'adage est la formule comme moi le
parti se prend à gauche parti se prend à
droite
c'est ce qu'a essayé de faire jean
françois copé en se positionnant sur ce
registre là mais pour moi ya pas de
différence
premier point lourde j'entends mais
surtout l'essentiel c'est quoi
l'ump c'est quoi à l'origine c'est
justement trois familles politiques qui
ont quelques différences ça a toujours
existé c'est pas de nouveaux appels
différentes familles différents courants
de pensée qui coexistent au sein de
l'ump
c'était l'objectif mais c'était
l'objectif même de l'ump
si vous vous rappelez des temps certes
un peu anciens mais quand même pas trop
facile vu que ça elle est une politique
portée du temps du rpr par alain juppé
d'un côté ou par charles pasqua l'autre
s'était pas tout à fait la même
laly stratégique n'est pas tout à fait
la même est on arrivé à cause de ce même
parti et donc l'objectif même de l'ump
qui deviennent devons faire vivre nos
familles au sein de la même étiquette me
paraît un objectif qu'il nous faut
continuer à poursuivre par exemple on
voit que jean françois copé pour la
rentrée va être très offensif il a parlé
plusieurs fois il a lancé un appel pour
aller manifester pour le mariage contre
le mariage pour tous
évidemment vous pensez que tous les
députés ump vont suivre cette cette
démarche
je te jure ce vient d'ouvrir encore ne
seront jamais très loin désormais et les
oppositions un père c'est bien pour ça
qu'il faut en sortir
c'est bien pour ça qu'il faut compter
deux adolescents parce qu'effectivement
comme vous le dit très justement au jeu
depuis il y à des membres du groupe ump
à l'assemblée nationale
j'en fais partie qui n'ont pas voulu
quitter ce groupe là pour rejoindre
l'autre mais qui ne se sentent pas à
l'aise aujourd'hui dans la famille
politique parce qu'il ya toujours cette
tâche entre guillemets sur l'élection du
président l'ump dont on doit sortir il
ya toujours cette crise politique dont
on doit sortir et donc évidemment il
restera un malaise tant que nous
n'aurons pas réglé le problème de fond à
savoir une élection totalement légitime
dû prendre l'ump on va parler d'autre
chose si vous voulez bien reprendre le
fil des audiences pour commenter les
autres infos mardi on a aussi beaucoup
parlé de florange à l'assemblée jean
marc ayrault et arnaud montebourg se
sont présentés ensemble à la réunion de
groupe socialiste ce mardi les caméras
ont même été autorisés à filmer une
image de la réunion ce qui est rare
histoire sans doute de montrer l'unité
affichée du mouvement du gouvernement il
faut dire que l'accord trouvé avec
mittal sur florange et chaque jour un
peu plus critique et rim benameur outre
l'ump un autre face à face est sous les
projecteurs jean marc ayrault arnaud
montebourg des rapports très tendus
depuis le rétropédalage sur la
nationalisation de florange
ambiance glaciale entre les deux hommes
lors de la réunion du groupe socialiste
quelques heures plus tard florange à
nouveau fait l'ouverture des questions
au gouvernement avec deux
interpellations de jean marc ayrault
l'une de christian jacob l'autre du
député de moselle michel liebgott le
premier ministre répond nous avons
obtenu un engagement du groupe métal et
ça a été une bataille difficile a fallu
créer un rapport de force il n'y aura
pas de plan social à mittal et à
florange et jean marc ayrault tente
d'arrondir les angles avec son ministre
du redressement productif aux ministres
particulièrement en pointe dans ce
dossier d'abord arnaud montebourg aucun
je tiens à rendre hommage
michel sapin delphine batho geneviève
fioraso d'être à mes côtés pour relever
le défi du développement économique et
industriel de la lorraine
soutien tardif comme en écho à l'appui
des députés ps
entendus toute la journée dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée tous les
ministres je dirais mais des
propositions après certaines sont soumis
à l'arbitrage une certaine ce ne sont
pas vous avez des ministres qui
préfèrent des maîtres off et faire le
canal de l'arbitrage arnaud montebourg
ni les aînés publiquement pourtant la
démonstration d'amitié ne convainc pas
droit c'est une seconde est qu'il faut
nationaliser que le premier ministre est
concret on voit bien que ce gouvernement
il tourne en rond le capitaine de
pédalos a trouvé la barre mais tomberont
et le feuilleton florange continue jean
marc ayrault recevra ce mercredi
l'intersyndicale de l'aciériste peu
convaincu par l'accord trouvé
alors la suite on la connaît recéleurs
mittal a fait savoir jeudi la commission
européenne qu'il ne voulait pas du
projet européen ulcos saint-projet de
prototypes innovants deux hauts
fourneaux mittal qui anéantit ainsi le
principal espoir de reprise de la
filière chaude de florange colère des
élus locaux qui étaient reçus jeudi à
matignon
nous avons des doutes et nous avons
encore des doutes
aujourd'hui nous sommes un peu rassuré
parce que son très relatif c'est un sur
le métal on a un courrier qui nous dit
une coche finalement on voit quand même
sur doute dans quelques années
bon nous on demande à vérifier et on ne
croira plus sur parole alors ce même élu
qui a dit que mitel avait entuber le
gouvernement vous êtes d'accord
côté cette affaire pour moi est mené de
façon ahurissante depuis le début entre
un ministre du redressement productif
qui dit mittal dehors c'est sur ces
déclarations qui donne de la confiance
entre les parties prenez goût c'est
quelque chose
un ministre qui nous dit michel dehors
et qu'il applique en dise enfin qu'il
applique qui fait des propositions en
disant il faut nationaliser et gérard
preneur puis un premier ministre après
la rubrique qui prenne le dossier en
disant allez montebourg rentrer à la
maison rentrer à bercy on va le gérer et
qui le gère de façon totalement
différente avec une autre option qui est
celle d'un accord avec monsieur mittal
tout en nous disant et tous les
ministres passent en boucle sur toutes
les chaînes
nous n'avons pas confiance en monsieur
mittal et pourtant signé avec eux et
donc je n'y connais sont entre
guillemets plus rien n'y a pas de ligne
effectivement sur ce dossier là est
whittall entre guillemets en profite est
ce qu'on peut reprocher à jean marc
ayrault d'avoir voulu sauver 610 emplois
m personne va reprocher à monsieur
ayrault de sa valse de vouloir sauver
six candidats encore la question c'est
de savoir si on y arrive
est-ce que c'est efficace c'est ça la
question
mais ça on verra dans les semaines à
venir
je le souhaite pour les 610 familles
concernées je le souhaite pour la
sidérurgie de rejoindre de lorraine
pardon je souhaite également bien
évidemment pour le gouvernement s'il
réussit j'applaudis simplement on voit
bien que quand vous n'avez pas de ligne
politique au sein d'un gouvernement
quand vous voulez pas cette ligne là
vous êtes fragile en négociation et vos
interlocuteurs
c'est une évidence selon vous c'est
arnaud montebourg qui demande la
nationalisation comme ça sans avoir
réellement peut-être moins on a pas à
dire à un chef d'entreprise qui emploie
vingt mille salariés au ciel à 601
florange milles 1 mille en france on dit
pas un chef d'entreprise d'or premier
point c'est pas un ministre qui fait ça
qu'un député entre guillemets excédé le
fasse passe encore un ministre il doit
tenir son rang doit tenir sa ligne il
assume la responsabilité au gouvernement
il n'a pas à s'exprimer comme ça premier
point
deuxième point nationaliser pourquoi pas
on peut imaginer dans certains cas de
figure une nationalisation je suis pas
choqué par le principe en tant que tel
mais la nationalisation chantage là
c'est ahurissant
soit tu fais ce que je te dis soit je
t'achète ça je suis désolé ça s'appelle
de la spoliation et pas de la
nationalisation c'est pas comme ça là
encore qu'on négocie vous auriez une
situation industrielle difficile comme
c'est le cas et un patron qui vous dit
désolé je n'ai pu rien faire je sais
plus comment sortir de cette boîte l'a
nationalisée mois et ensemble on va
essayer de redresser la barre je peux
comprendre une nationalisation de ce
point de vue là mais la socialisation
qui consiste à dire un monsieur mittal
d'or 2 tu veut pas négocier
je prends ça n'a aucune chance de
fonctionner preuve en est
malheureusement et sur le fond pour les
un petit peu plus loin quand on dit en
france peut-être qu'il faut se dire
aussi comme dit jacques attali mais qui
est des produits qu'on ne peut plus
fabriqué en france comme l'acier parce
que ça nous coûte trop d'argent à ce que
fait est-ce qu'on peut l'entendre sa
part pense qu'il faut d'entendre je
pense qu'il faut
mais peut-être partie du fond du
problème mais je pense que c'est l'un
des fonds du problème bien évidemment
c'est que nous n'assumons pas ses choix
économiques de temps en temps sarkozy y
compris on a vu pour d'autres qu'elles
étaient guidées à mon avis à poursuivre
dans la filière entre guillemets
florange vous savez comme moi qu'il ya
deux parties ya une partie qui est
aujourd'hui en gros la production acte
d'acier en tant que tel pas rentable
et puis voilà et la transformation de
l'acier et les rentables il ya un moment
effectivement il faut accepter de faire
des choix stratégiques sur le plan
industriel
en dix ans ce qui peut marcher en france
et ce qui peut nous permettre de
redresser l'industrie c'est l'industrie
haut de gamme
c'est d'ailleurs les conclusions du
rapport de monsieur gallois l'industrie
haut de gamme essaie de se réorienter
sur ces niches qui sont des niches à
forte valeur ajoutée qui nous permet de
conserver les mettre de côté il ya un
moment ou un autre
quand la tonne d'acier vos x en france x
à à produire en chine et qu'en plus le
marché s'effondre
effectivement il ya un moment ça un
problème moi je veux bien qu'on
maintienne en france une usine pour
fabriquer des appareils photo comme on
appelle ça suit les anciens les
actionnaires il fauteuil pellicule va
effectivement on peut bâtir une usine
sauf que produit ils marchent plus voilà
c'est comme ça les argentique voilà fait
tellement vieux qu'on se souvient fusion
non là encore maintenant bataillon
nationalisons mais terne l'argent sur
des filières qui ont un avenir mais
maintenir des filières qu'ils n'ont pas
d'avenir à 1 - abîme paraît risqué et je
précise tout de suite que je ne suis pas
suffisamment fins connaisseurs du
dossier technique de mittal pour savoir
si en l'occurrence là dans ce dossier
précis on peut maintenir ou pas quand on
va en parler maintenant d'un autre thème
benoist apparu un thème qui vous est
cher parce que vous avez été ministre du
logement et on va parler du logement et
de la nouvelle ministre cécile duflot
l'a demandé en début de semaine la
réquisition des logements qui
appartiennent à l'église et le moins
qu'on puisse dire bien sûr c'est que
cette proposition a fait beaucoup parler
écouter cet échange lors des questions
d'actualité entre bruno le maire et la
ministre madame la ministre vous avez
cru bon de vous en prendre à l'église
catholique
pour réclamer la réquisition des
logements disponibles
si vous tenez tant que ça à la
réquisition réquisitionner les logements
de fonction dont dispose la ville de
paris et le conseil régional
d'ile-de-france réquisitionner tous les
logements des fonctionnaires qui ne
répondent pas à une unité de service
public au lieu de céder à la polémique
facile madame duflot
n'oubliez pas un principe populaire
charité bien ordonnée commence par soi
même
des milliers d'associations des milliers
d'associatifs de bénévoles se mobilisent
pour lutter contre la crise du logement
et le gouvernement le fait le fait grâce
au vote la semaine dernière d'une loi
qui permettra de céder du foncier public
grâce à une loi qui permettra contre
laquelle vous avez voté de perdre 25 %
de logement social dans toutes les
agglomérations et ce n'est pas un
fabricant en essayant d'inventer une
polémique que vous nous ferez fléchir
par rapport à la volonté qui est de
répondre à ceux et celles qui
aujourd'hui en ont besoin alors la
sortie de cécile duflot intentionnelle
ou maladroite j'en sais rien mais en
tout cas une erreur ça c'est sur une
erreur pourquoi parce que quand on
connaît un peu ce milieu associatif
quelles sont les grandes structures
associatives du milieu entre guillemets
qui luttent contre les personnes qui
sont à la rue vous avez fondation abbé
pierre
on voit bien l'origine emmaüs on voit
bien là origines secours catholique
on voit bien l'origine ordre de malte on
voit bien l'origine ça sont les grands
réseaux associatifs et à côté des grands
réseaux ciotti vous avez toute une série
de petites associations de quartier qui
travaille également souvent autour des
paroisses donc prendre comme bouc
émissaire
les banquiers je trouve ça ridicule
parce que on n'a pas à prendre des boucs
émissaires mais prendre comme bouc
émissaire
une institution qui fait déjà un boulot
considérable me paraît totalement hors
de propos
donc c'est un temps qu'une erreur j'en
sais rien ça fout le poser la question
des dérivatifs finalement à je pense que
c'est la technique du bouc émissaire
vous savez quand vous n'êtes pas à
l'aise dans vos baskets sur un sujet
vous créez une bonne polémique en
dérivatif en tapant sur quelqu'un est
effectivement vous fait oublier le fond
du problème parce que le résultat c'est
qu'on ne peut pas
le pas effectivement de la politique
qu'elle mène mais sam de la polémique
qui a été créée pas de la politique qui
est menée selon les chiffres vous les
connaissez aussi aussi bien sûrement que
cécile duflot il ya 1500 demandes
d'urgence par jour qui ne sont pas
donnés comme on ne peut pas mettre les
gens dans des services qu'est ce que
vous en pensez plus compliqué que ça il
faut faire toujours très attention aux
chiffres en la matière pourquoi parce
que quand une personne va téléphoner
cette fois la même personne va
téléphoner cette fois on va compter
cette fois la demande
il faut nuancer les chiffres par rapport
à ça pour regarder quels sont les
contenus
je vais pas jeter la pierre à cécile
duflot c'est une charge très complexe et
malheureusement beaucoup de gens ont le
sentiment qu'il suffit de claquer des
doigts pour effectivement pouvoir sortir
ceux qui sont à la rue et les abriter ou
les mettre dans un logement
malheureusement c'est mille fois plus
complexe que ça ce qui est compliqué
dans cette histoire c'est quoi c'est
qu'évidemment quand pendant cinq ans
matin midi et soir tous les hivers on a
donné des leçons de morale à la terre
entière
quand les élus europe ecologie les verts
de la ville de paris mme accusé
d'assassinât d'assassinât parce que je
laissais entre guillemets les gens
mourir dehors et ben maintenant
effectivement le réveil est difficile et
on s'aperçoit ils s'aperçoivent qu'il
suffit pas de claquer des doigts pour
régler ce douloureux problème résultat
qu'est ce qu'on fait on trouve un bon
bouc émissaire on lui tape dessus ont
créé une polémique et on parle pu livrer
un problème c'est au mercredi quand le
sénat fait passer un texte en douce oui
le vote a eu lieu en toute discrétion
dans la nuit le sénat s'est prononcé
pour l'autorisation de la recherche sur
l'embryon et sur les cellules souches
il s'agit d'une rupture majeure avec le
régime actuel d'interdiction et qui
bride les chercheurs fabrice qu'une et
depuis la loi sur la bioéthique de 2011
la recherche sur l'embryon étaient
interdites sauf rares dérogations très
encadrée la proposition de loi adoptée
mardi dans la nuit autorise désormais ce
genre de travaux à l'origine du texte
jacques mézard défend cette
clarification une volonté de
clarification et aussi il faut le dire
la volonté d'aller dans le sens de
de l'avenir du progrès car les
dispositions qui étaient applicables à
la suite de la loi de 2011 était
extrêmement compliqué et mettez nos
chercheurs dans des situations
extrêmement difficiles que l'on rejet
l'adoption à une large majorité au sénat
de l'autorisation sous contrôle de la
recherche sur l'embryon ne fait pas
oublier le débat qui entoure cette
question
au-delà de l'aspect éthique pour ses
détracteurs
ce serait aussi un non sens scientifique
les progrès faut plutôt à rechercher du
côté des cellules souches adultes et non
pas des cellules embryonnaires est le
message que nous avons envoyé hier soi
est un message qui me semble assez en
décalage avec eux l'actualité
scientifique et quand on sait que les
crédits alloués à la recherche
relativement limité je pense qu'il eût
été préférable d'en rester à la loi de
l'idée a pourtant reçu le soutien de la
ministre geneviève fioraso alors
cellules souches ou cellules souches
embryonnaires
la communauté scientifique a peut-être
récemment donné un signal le dernier
prix nobel de médecine ainsi récompenser
des travaux sur des cellules souches
adultes
alors il s'agit d'un vote en première
lecture le gouvernement pourra très bien
décider de la sève ne l'amenaient ou pas
à l'assemblée nationale c'est un peu à
sa guise
mais il change tout c'est pascal virage
à 180 degrés avec la loi de 2011
moi je suis très sceptique sur le vote
qui a été fait au sénat pourquoi la loi
de 2011 est une loi qui a demandé un an
de débat public un an de débat avec les
français avec les professionnels avant
de déboucher sur un texte sur ces
matières alain sur ces sujets là on ne
peut pas nuitamment voter quelque chose
sans avoir préalablement organiser la
consultation et on ne peut pas alors que
la loi bioéthique de 2011 faisait pas
forcément consensus parce qu'il ya
toujours débat bien évidemment sur ce
sujet là mais faisait relativement
autorités comme ça là encore du jour au
lendemain sans débat sans prévenir
quiconque tout changer ça ne me paraît
pas de bonne politique et permettent
quand même
justement que certaines cellules souches
sont utilisés pour la recherche
c'est quand même plutôt positifs dont
vous savez moi j'ai une inquiétude en
france aujourd'hui c'est
qu'effectivement on est devenus
un pays frileux surtout avec le principe
de précaution
érigée à peu près surtout justement ça
va plutôt dans le bon sens est arrivé
pas touche aux ogm pas tout je sais pas
quoi penser à nos technologies pas
touche pas touche pas tous les cours
sont faits plus rien du tout ou en tout
cas on bride des recherches
donc je suis pas sur le principe
intellectuelle consistant à dire
autorisons des recherches contre ce
principe là je suis plutôt favorable
simplement là encore si on veut éviter
les polémiques stériles
comment on en allier souvent la
méconnaissance des sujets comment la dea
politique sur le mes connaissances liées
par exemple aux ogm ou un sentiment que
tous les ogm sont les mêmes si on veut
traiter de façon ces sujets là compliqué
de façon sereine et intelligente
ça nécessite un débat serein et
intelligent et pas un truc en catimini
si ce texte arrive à l'assemblée
nationale nouveautés pauvreté contre
août et je me suis pas pour la santé
quasiment pour je ne sais pas je me
prononcerai le moment venu pour
l'instant la venue de voir ce qu'il en
sortira il aurait dit oui sur des sujets
comme ça c'est indispensable
allez on va passer au jeudi peut-on
parler d'une affaire cahuzac
c'est le site mediapart qui a lancé
l'information le ministre du budget
jérôme cahuzac aurait possédé un compte
en suisse jusqu'en 2010 information
catégoriquement démentie par l'intéressé
en ce jeudi chacun campe sur ses
positions
jean marais jean marc ayrault continue
lui à soutenir son ministre
thibault le floch fidèle à son habitude
mediapart distille ses infos au fur et à
mesure hier soir le site internet a mis
en ligne une conversation d'environ 4
minutes
on y entend deux hommes discutent et et
selon mediapart l'un d'entre eux serait
jérôme cahuzac
l'enregistrement daterait de fin 2000
jérôme cahuzac est déjà député mais il
est alors en course pour la mairie de
villeneuve sur lot
difficile d'identifier avec certitude la
voix du ministre du budget sur cet
enregistrement qui pose plus de
questions qu'il n'apporte de réponses
d'ailleurs si comme l'affirmé mediapart
jérôme cahuzac a fermé son compte en
2010 pourquoi at il attendu dix ans
entre cette conversation et la fermeture
du compte présumés difficile de le
savoir pour l'instant mercredi après le
conseil des ministres
jérôme cahuzac aurait soutenu devant
françois hollande et jean marc ayrault
que les accusations à son encontre sont
fausses
conséquence ce matin le premier ministre
apporte publiquement son soutien
moi je fais toute confiance jérôme
cahuzac on a déjà accusé de ne pas avoir
payé normalement son logement il a donné
toutes les explications nécessaires donc
je suis à ses côtés
mais mediapart persiste et signe selon
le site d'information c'est bien jérôme
cahuzac que l'on entend au téléphone le
ministre a lui choisi de déposer plainte
hier contre mediapart pour diffamation
benoist apparu affaire délicate a
commenté évidemment est ce que vous
demanderiez quand même comme laurent
wauquiez une audition de jérôme cahuzac
devant la commission des finances pour
répondre à certaines zones d'ombré
s'expliquer sur certaines zones dont
notamment son voyage en suisse
donc non donc on ne demanderait pas pour
une raison très simple il ya un truc qui
s'appelle le droit et dans le
journalisme des preuves
on en a ou en a pas si on en a on y va
si on en a pas on se tait ça me paraît
très simple comme principe l'an
l'occurrence le sentiment qu'on peut
avoir
s'il n'y a pas de preuves il n'y a rien
du tout y'a pas grand chose de dossiers
pas étayées c'est uniquement une un
témoin qui commence à recueillir son
témoignage et un témoin qui semble-t-il
harceler monsieur cahuzac pendant des
années un témoin qui effectivement est
telle qu'un la retraite mais qui est
juste un témoin points qui étaye son
truc sur à rien et 90 % de ce qu'il a
dit a déjà prouvé comme faux
et puis un enregistrement où le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que la capacité
à reconnaître de façon lourde
la voix de monsieur cahuzac est assez
limité je suis désolé ce n'est pas comme
ça de mon point de vue qu'on fait
justice en france et on va pas commencer
sous prétexte qu'une personne accuse
monsieur x depuis je ne sais quoi
d'auditionner le ministre en question ne
rentre pas dans la brèche
alors qu'il n'arrivait pas à rentrer
dans la baraque et vous aussi
mais fatigué mon métier c'est pas
d'attaqué pour le principe d'attaqué
c'est d'attaquer devant effectivement il
ya quelque chose de juste a attaqué l'an
l'occurrence de mon point de vue c'est
injuste donc je n'ai pas attaqué je suis
pas un socialiste avec l'affairé woerth
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait mais je n'ai
pas envie de me mêler ça j'ai pas envie
de faire comme eux comme les erreurs
qu'ils ont commises en détruisant entre
guillemets l'honneur d'un homme
à l'époque ils s'en sont lavés les mains
de cet honneur ils se sont lavés les
mains de l'appréhension de j'entends
bien faire j'ai entend bien on verra le
résultat pour l'instant il ya eu
d'accord je vous rappelle un point sur
la ferveur toile et dans l'autre sens
non plus j'entends bien sûr l'affairé
woerth il ya eu 15 allégations 14 sont
complètement tombé à la trappe
et pourtant les quatorze ont été pris
bille en tête aux quatre colonnes en
question d'actualité par les socialistes
eh ben je ne ferai pas la même chose que
vous écoutez non je condamne pas
spécifiquement mediapart
il fait son boulot que comme il entend
le faire simplement c'est pas à moi à
tomber dans le piège et c'est pas à nous
effectivement en sur demande et le
boulou mediapart c'est comme d'apporter
des preuves de ce qu'ils avancent
on ne doit pas finir cette émission va
t'amener sur un taux un petit peu plus
léger c'est le plus de l'hebdo
et benoît parloir parler de la presse et
des journalistes encore mais cela est
bien on ne les entend pas souvent une
bonne pas souvent la parole pourtant
vous devez sûrement voir leur travail
presque tous les jours ce solide et
dessinateur de presse 90 dessins sont
exposés sur les grilles du jardin du
luxembourg vont avoir quelques uns avec
le reportage de nathalie d'ivoire
interpellé visiblement ces dessins
suscite l'attention des passants même
des plus pressés sur les grilles
sentences ont passé en revue à travers
des caricatures de signer
cabu plantu des dessins de presse qui
représente des événements marquants bon
parce que ça me rappelle quelque chose
le blocage du canal de suez
ça a été une opération
internationale qui a failli déclencher
une guerre mondiale je suis devant
quelques images des trente glorieuses et
ça m'a remémoré un temps effectivement
on avait vraiment de la chance on se
faisait pas de souci pour l'avenir de la
nostalgie mais pas que ces caricatures
rafraîchisse la mémoire des passants
mais aussi les interpelle fait réagir à
mener la réflexion si c'est que permet
le dessin de presse selon jacques la
malle et patrice lestrohan c'est à la
fois pour se remémorer les événements ou
les découvrir les grands événements du
siècle on parle souvent de la pensée
unique mais le dessin plaire mechner de
lutter contre la perception unique
cette exposition est tiré de leurs
livres elle se déroule jusqu'au 1er mars
2013 aux grilles du jardin du luxembourg
benoist apparu je vous présente olivier
ranson vous pouvez peut-être voir ses
dessins parce que tous les jours dans le
quotidien aujourd'hui en france le
parisien
merci d'être venu avec moi sur ce
plateau
il est déjà en train de dessiner et de
croquer un petit peu la vie politique
qu'est ce qui vous inspire dans
l'actualité du jour ou en tout cas de la
semaine
monsieur rançon écoutez je veux dire
d'abord moi mon choix n'importe auto
puisque c'est le journal qui décide ce
qui va mettre en fait du jour en
ouverture et par conséquent je dessine
sur ce qu'on va essayer de promouvoir
comme actualité alors je remercie
monsieur apparu parce que la semaine
dernière j'ai eu fillon et copé jusqu'à
plus soif et que c'était réellement
délectable c'était un sujet qui
rebondissait tous les jours et qu'ils
ont croqué un petit peu on peut dire ça
voilà et des combats cette semaine je
commence avec art si l'or et je trouve
que c'est bien aussi
personnage montebourg il avait déjà
brillé en s'affichant courageusement en
marinière
e
pour promouvoir le made in france saf et
unificateur oui ça ça fait une image eux
donc je ne sais pas combien de temps il
va rester ministre mais je pense que sa
marinière va rester aussi longtemps que
lui voilà un dessin de presse vous le
redouté autant voire plus parfois qu'à
un bon papier oui parce qu'il est
beaucoup plus visible plus cruel aussi
quelques ruelles aussi donc est plus
simple un bon papier de presse vous le
prenez au début à la fin là quand vous
avez un dessin vous avez une image qui
vous fait donc c'est beaucoup plus cruel
potentiellement beaucoup plus simple
beaucoup plus rapide mais beaucoup plus
efficace
benoist apparu ont vaguement des
ressources qui l'emportent mais est ce
que vous voyez souvent les hommes
politiques il ya des journalistes
éditorialistes qui rencontrent pour
déjeuner avec les hommes politiques vous
voulez rencontrer ou pas non je les
croise il y en a aucun ou rarement qui
m'invite à déjeuner germanier ça peut
changer mais
pour moi c'est je dire le travail est
fait à l'extérieur
je me documente avec ce que je lis dans
la presse ce que je vois sur les autres
médias
tenez votre rapport au politique est
complètement différent des journalistes
de la rédaction d autres journalistes
je travaille moi sur le travail des
autres donc je n'ai pas besoin d'avoir
de l'information directement la sauce je
peux vous dire c'est la première fois
qu'un homme politique avait parlé d'un
de mes dessins ça devait être en 1987 ou
88 c'était françois léotard pour un
dessin que j'avais fait au matin de
paris et le journaliste politique était
revenue avait dit les retards a pas du
tout aimé ton dessin moi j'avais dit à
me regarde tient ou ça fait très content
mais ça m'étonnait que ça ait autant
d'incidents s'est autant d'importance
des journaux les plus lus de france donc
je vous remercie de souligner que c'est
dû à mon talent vous avez déjà je suis
en train oui ça qui vous a vraiment
marqué ou pas au long de ces longues
années de politique maintenant moi celui
qui m'a le vin l'un d'eux ce qui m'a
marqué en tout cas que j'ai vraiment
toujours en mémoire c'est le dessin de
plantu sur la fameuse affaire gordji
sais pas si vous savez si vous souvenez
vous avez cette espèce de cordon
sanitaire autour de l'ambassade d'iran
où avec un attaché culturel censé avoir
à poser des bombes etc etc
et puis du jour au lendemain ça sort et
vous aviez cette rencontre entre le juge
boulouque si mes souvenirs sont bons et
monsieur willy gorgi où le juge
d'interrogent pas walid bourgi sur la
faire mais pour cent pour organiser son
retour en iran lui demandant s'il veut
ainsi en première classe ou 2e classe
voilà c'était d'une férocité
extraordinaire au à un moment
excessivement tendue sur le plan de la
politique intérieure l'appétit des
rafales sur ce sujet là alors pensons à
ce que vous pouvez nous montrer votre
voilà il signe le dessin et on va
pouvoir démontrer vous allez montrer
face à la caméra qui est juste devant
vous du jour
ensemble voilà donc j'ai très hâtivement
dessinée hollande héros et montebourg en
marinière avec un casque et le type à
côté dit ils sont solidaires ils portent
le casque par solidarité il fait non je
crois plutôt qu'ils essayent de se
couvrir dessin du jour de rançon ah ben
c'est eux mais je pense que j'aurais
plutôt vu effectivement les trois se
mettant des coups de casque les uns
contre les autres mais c'est autre chose
webb a peut-être que ça vous donnera
aussi de des idées pour la solution
chaîne votre idée pour copé fillon au
moment je me suis dit je me suis dit zut
latif une grosse connerie
merci d'être venus merci beaucoup
benoist apparu de leur participation au
dos aux trop bien son projet bien sûr
même lieu même heure au revoir avant